using compounds that create the glow of
a fireflies beli researchers were able
to image cells deep in the brain of this
marmoset for over a year the blinking
globe or bioluminescence of fireflies
comes from a chemical reaction in their
lower abdomens reaction varies slightly
from species to species but it's all
based on an enzyme and a compound coming
together with a little oxygen and ATP as
the reaction goes forward light is
emitted scientists have been using
variations on this reaction for decades
to non-invasively observe biological
processes and cells and small laboratory
animals but the light from these systems
was not very bright and needed to be
pretty close to the surface to be seen
now researchers have engineered a
modified luciferase luciferin pair that
glows up to 1,400 times brighter
researchers used directed evolution to
improve the enzymes activity they
introduced randomly mutated versions of
the enzyme into bacteria then sprayed
the bacterial colonies with a
specialized substrate the colonies that
glowed the brightest were selected and
mutated again 21 generations later the
optimized enzyme substrate pair glowed
much brighter and was less toxic to
cells
the brighter glow was due in part to the
fact that the substrate was engineered
to emit light in a different part of the
spectrum redder light passes more easily
through tissue and the evolved enzyme
was able to process the substrate faster
meaning more glowing reactions in less
time these improvements allowed the
detection of cells and living animals
much deeper inside the animal and with
more precision using a camera sensitive
to near-infrared light researchers were
able to detect single transplanted tumor
cells in the lung of a living Mouse the
equivalent of detecting a single firefly
and a space the size of a high school
gym they were also able to monitor the
activity of specific neurons in mice in
reaction to novel environments and they
followed cells deep in the brain of the
marmoset over the course of a year
in the future this new imaging technique
that helps scientists learn about where
stem cells end up aid in monitoring the
success of gene editing and even track
tumor growth in cancer patients
[Music]